all right
hey
okay okay so i'll start and then i'll
pass it on to you in a few slides okay
okay
so we'll give it just a few more minutes
we have about five more minutes and uh
and
once we start
we're gonna try and cover the
introduction to bioinformatics and
genomics so
[Music]
hopefully we'll do it faster than in an
hour
or two hours
yeah
so in the morning today when i sent the
email i sent to only those people who
filled out the forms
so so that it doesn't go like a to 1000
people you know
yeah yeah
so it's around like 55
of them
[Music]
all right so we're going to be starting
here in just a couple more minutes um in
the meantime
i just want to remind everyone that we
have a page where you submitted your
registration and you should have gotten
that zoom link
but
for people that just
now submitted i see a couple of people
submitted just now
i hope that they will be getting the
link in time as well
so
okay so um maybe to begin
i'll just introduce a little bit the
project and then i'll pass it on to for
hana to say a couple of words about
what we're going to be doing today
so um
omixlogic
is a bioinformatics education portal
that was designed to address some of the
needs in bioinformatics education and
data science education across
the
louisiana biomedical research network
and the national association of idea
principal investigators
one of our objectives is to
develop resources that are easy to use
specifically designed for biologists and
non-bioinformaticians and we hope to
learn today about the interest in a
variety of different applications of
bioinformatics
including several different types of
omics data
so the program was recently announced at
the southeastern
nepe
or southeastern idea meeting and here
you can see on the slide
uh dr august kasulis who was announcing
this project
and
making sure
that we have
faculty as well as students so this is
designed for both undergraduate and
graduate students and that everyone
knows
that this is available for free
it's going to be covered by different
institutions that will discuss today how
the registration is going to work
but the key point is that this is going
to be available for free for those that
are either from
lsu louisiana biomedical research
network or from any um
nepe project
so um to give this a little bit more
introduction i will pass it on to
farahana
for hana is a postdoctoral student at
um
lsu
and so she'll briefly talk about these
programs and registration right and then
i'll kind of cover what's going to be in
each one of these programs
hi everyone
this is farhana i am a postdoctoral
researcher in dr kosila's lab in
louisiana state university
so
this semester we are offering these
three courses
one is the introduction uh to
bioinformatics that is for the very like
beginner it's a
uh
it's good for undergraduate students and
whoever never had any
bioinformatics course before
the second course that we are offering
is the genomics and meta genomic data
analysis it's a
intermediate level course
and
afterwards uh if for those who are very
interested and have previous uh
knowledge about bioinformatics they can
take the advanced level course which is
the data science for biomedical data and
intermediates
so um
in the
flyer that we sent you earlier
and can i share my screen
i don't know whether i can share my
screen ilia
i think you can know
okay
so can you see
my screen now
now you have to press on share did you
do that
okay so this is the flyer
okay
so most of you already received this
flyer
and in the flyer we have a link here
that actually shows uh
like if you click in on the link it will
take you to the website and you can you
will see that there is a form that you
have to submit
uh so that we know that the people are
interested in this course
and once you submit this form we will
send you notification and other
information about the courses so this is
what the course schedules are so the
first course the introduction to
bioinformatics starts in january 24th
that is next week and it's a pretty much
a month long course
the second uh course the genomics and
genomic data analysis starts on the 25th
of january and it's a little bit big
longer than the first course it ends on
the march 22nd
and you can either take the genomics or
the meta genomics data analysis
and
last course starts on january 27 until
april 21st
so to
um
before you take these courses you have
to register through lsu
most more specifically
via the gene lab
so to register it first of all you have
to have
um an ilab
account
so after this orientation session i will
send you all the links and
important informations on how to
register
so first you need to create an account
in the ilab
or the gene lab the people who are
already in the lsu vet school you guys
already use the ilab for utilizing some
of the instruments it's a core facility
for us
whoever doesn't have the account they
have to sign up and sometimes some of
the students already faced this issue
that their pis names are not on the link
on this system so for those people they
have to
like inform us their pi name
email address
and phone number so that we can include
the bi in this system so once you have
the
once you sign up
once you sign up
for an account you will see a page like
this
and then
i will scroll down here
just call down here and
um
you have to create an account and then
you sign in
and after you sign in
you will see uh
on the left hand side the core
facilities
you have to click on that core
facilities and then you will see
uh the course cedar core facilities and
services you have to click on that
and after that you will see a page like
this
and then on the right side on top corner
you will see the request services
so
it will take you to the
training module
once you click on the request service
it will take you to the training module
and you can see and select like what are
the courses that you are interested in
whether you are
in taking the one course the first
course are all of them you will select
those courses
and then
right now you don't see it here but if
the updated system will have the names
of the courses then you can
select it
afterwards
you have to put the phone number
if you are outside the lsu or they'll be
rn program then you have to have your
specific fund number
for us otherwise you just write lsu or
lprn
and then we will put the account number
here so after that you will just have to
submit the request to us and we will go
through all the information and then
we'll accept it and then the
registration will be complete
so after this orientation session i will
i will send you all about the
informations and everything
and the procedure how to register so
that if there is any confusion you can
look at it and after that if there's any
other questions i would be happy to help
you just contact me
that's it i guess ilya
all right thank you for hannah so again
this was just
a little clarification about how you can
register
and what i will do is go over the actual
content of this program to really
explain what are the differences between
these
three different programs
so
as for hana already mentioned we're
going to have these three programs
introduction to bioinformatics genomics
and data science
in fact here you can see that it's going
to be either genomics or metagenomics
we'll talk more in depth about
metagenomics in the
uh
in our next orientation session but
today we're going to just cover
introduction to bioinformatics and
genomics
so before we begin
i already posted a link
in the chat
this portal is where you're going to be
able to access all of the material so
the registration that for hana mentioned
this is to get yourself registered
according to the three different options
either you are from lsu
and then you have to register to ilab
and mention that you're from lsu
or if you are from
lbrn which is louisiana biomedical
research network then you also register
to io lab for everybody else you can
just directly register on this onyx
logic portal and within the portal
you'll be able to specify
which institution you're from uh so just
make sure that you are mentioning your
um you're using your email address from
your institution and then and if you're
a part of netbean
mention that in your file so once you go
to this link again this link is in the
chat you will see
an option to create an account
and so this account is going to be
important to uh
use and i'll explain in a little bit why
and how that is going to be used for
certification
once you are registered
you will be given several options and
those options will include some basic
access
um or some advanced access so don't
choose those options
we will be
sending out a follow-up email and if you
have registered and you want to
participate in one of the programs we
will be reaching out to you
if you're a part of nepe
that's going to be again free of cost so
at this moment you can take a couple of
minutes and just
create an account or log into your
account and i will show you
where in this account you will be able
to use different areas to
get access to this upcoming training
so on the uh on your account once you're
in and again all you need is your email
address or you can use your social media
or something like this
please update your name
and if you are a part of netbe if you
are in a lab you're a student in the lab
or you're a pi
just mention it right here under your
description there's going to be a little
section for bio that way we will know
to reach out to you with the right
information
after you have completed your profile we
will be using this profile to track your
progress and recommend additional
training um that you will find on the
portal and i will go over
this training today
so you will
after completing certain requirements of
the program you will be able to receive
the certificate and that certificate
will be issued based on where you came
from so either you will get a
certificate from
lsu
and it will be signed from someone from
lsu
or from lbrn louisiana biomedical
research network or
from nepi the national association of
idea principal investigators
okay so just give it two more minutes if
you still have not created an account
here please do so now
and if you have already maybe you can
mention that in chat
and i'm just getting notifications about
people registering so i'm just
going to give it a couple more minutes
okay so once you have registered and you
have again added your name
and a little description here about
yourself that should include whether you
are from a specific institution uh part
of nepy or lbrn or lsu please mention
that right here
all right thank you and if you have
already if you mentioned this in the
chat box that would be very helpful as
well
so
first of all
how do you
get started
the first program that we're going to
discuss is called introduction to
bioinformatics so if you have minimal
background with bioinformatics you don't
really have any experience maybe you
have read and you have heard and you're
interested in it but you don't really
have any practical experience
this is the best place to start
now you will be able to register for
multiple programs for example you can
take introduction to bioinformatics
first and then once you complete it you
can go on to the more advanced programs
those advanced programs could include
all three of the other programs genomics
metagenomics or data science
but first for those that don't have any
background we recommend getting started
with this introductory program
now this introductory program includes
several modules and these are
introduction to bioinformatics
bytes and molecules
bioinformatics and r and bioinformatics
and python so this will really orient
you with some terminology and some basic
skills for you to get started it is
typically something that you can
complete about in about a month's time
so that's why we're offering for those
that complete introduction to
bioinformatics to continue on to the
more advanced programs
as soon as you have registered you will
already have access to all of these
materials some of them are completely
free and some of them will have some
free modules that you can just test and
see if that's something that you would
like to do
so these are found and again i'll just
quickly switch here to the portal
once you're logged in
sorry
so once you're logged in for example
this is my profile
you can see here information about
myself and then if i click right here on
courses i can scroll or search or right
here you will see getting started so if
you click on getting started
you will see these modules that i was
just showing on the screen
introduction to bioinformatics bytes and
molecules bioinformatics and r and
bioinformatics and python so these are
some of the starting materials that we
will cover
now beyond that what we will do in the
program
is we will use these basic modules to
see the applications of bioinformatics
to learn about the terminology that is
commonly used with bioinformatics
methods we're going to do a little
introduction to coding with python and r
just so that you're aware of what goes
into some of these methods of analysis
and then we will provide you with access
to some introductory projects so these
projects are going to show you how
people that have used bioinformatics in
a variety of domains like infectious
diseases oncology and others
have been able to use the method the
methods that we cover in these programs
to achieve research results so what
actually went in there so the way you
can find those is first of all there's
the search field you can search for
example for ebola
or you can look over here on tags and
these tags include some typical
types of materials that you will find
and down here we have organized them
into these
sections sections for getting started
sections in r sections in python
projects etc
so the one we just discussed was getting
started which is right here
now beyond that once you are getting
comfortable with how things are
organized and you understand how to
navigate the site you'll be able to find
a lot of additional materials that you
can just try and do on your own
asynchronously
so let's talk briefly about this uh
omnix logic programs in general first
and then we'll jump into introduction to
bioinformatics
so as a part of this initiative we have
collected materials from a variety of
researchers
that address these specific types of
applications of bioinformatics so first
of all introduction and general overview
of bioinformatics genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics epigenomics
and data science
these will be offered throughout the
year including in the summer a specific
program around
a research fellowship and this research
fellowship will provide you with an
opportunity to work on an independent
project so the idea here is to provide
training with basic skills and then to
offer a variety of applications
including oncology uh infectious
diseases
neuroscience agriculture biotechnology
and others
so what typically goes into a training
program like this
are a collection of resources that we
will be providing
for those that participate so first of
all you will have access to the training
materials those training materials will
be completely asynchronous you will be
able to find them on this portal but you
will also have a program page that will
organize these materials into a sequence
once you complete each one of those you
will also be sent a video that you can
watch that explains how the different
elements of this program are combined
together
you will also have access to a big data
analysis platform that you can use to
analyze
public domain data and some of those
public domain data sets are going to be
explained in the materials that you will
be provided you will also find elements
of code that you can get started with to
apply what you have learned in r and
python and some explanations on how to
do that so what does the syntax mean
what does it do some examples that you
can try right in the browser and an
explanation of how you can take that and
use it on your own system
now the previous programs that we have
run
we tried to address the needs of those
that want to learn about but also apply
what they have learned to their current
research
and to
project sometimes citizen science
projects sometimes research projects and
we have quite a number of people that
were successful at completing the
program and learning about how to apply
these methods in their uh
research
that they were a part of
so what we
want to cover in this first program the
introduction to bioinformatics is to
provide a general overview to those that
don't have a lot of experience already
with bioinformatics so this will include
bioinformatics and big data how big data
and the need for computational
technologies is changing bioinformatics
including an introduction to a variety
of omics types of data
and then to methods of analysis the
basic statistical analysis as well as
machine learning for a variety of these
types of onyx data
we will touch on
the scripting aspect but that will
really be minimal it's not intended to
be
in-depth about any one particular
language or application it's really to
provide you with a sense of what
bioinformatics is and how to apply it in
a general theoretical sense and so
hopefully this is something that anyone
with any background can participate in
and benefit from just learning about the
terminology so the three main things
that we will cover are informatics
statistics and biology and so what that
means is that we will talk a little bit
about what kinds of information
technologies uh what kinds of
statistical and analytical methods and
what kinds of applications of
bioinformatics
are important to understanding and how
that is changing different fields where
bioinformatics is used so primarily we
will try to talk about this from the
perspective of
biology and data so how does data
describe biology and how can we study
biological phenomena using different
types of data that provide us with this
detailed view of what's going on
but we will also talk about the
applications of bioinformatics in
clinical
and different industry projects as well
specifically in biomedical application
to diagnostics and selection of
therapeutics or discovery of
therapeutics and things like that
now we
will cover several different types of
omics
including genomics epigenomics and
transcriptomics but very uh
superficially so there won't be any
in-depth explanation in this particular
introduction to bioinformatics program
it is just going to provide you with the
sense of what does this data describe
and what does this data look like
to understand what it looks like we're
going to also cover several publicly
available data repositories where you
can explore
projects that have been submitted by
researchers across many different types
of labs and you will be able to find a
variety of different project examples
that are typically associated with a
publication so hopefully you will find
some relevance to whatever field you're
involved in
now as i mentioned one of the challenges
in bioinformatics is being able to not
only learn about bioinformatics but
practically experience what
bioinformatics can do for you and so to
introduce you to different methods of
analysis of bioinformatics we have a
platform called the t-balancer platform
that is color-coded with explained
methods that allows for a variety of
inputs and outputs and really will
provide you with a guided process to
understand the logic of bioinformatics
so for those that are getting started
this is the best way to go from
general understanding to practical
application quickly right and hopefully
that also reinforces the logic of why am
i doing what i'm doing and what am i
expecting to get out of this uh process
that we call a pipeline or a workflow
so to summarize the introduction to
bioinformatics program is going to
explain how big data is used in
bioinformatics or biomedical research we
will talk briefly about
sorry we will talk briefly about the
applications of bioinformatics
there we go
different types of technologies
and some concepts of data science that
are going to be useful as you continue
to explore what bioinformatics can offer
and so to see a detailed curriculum
you can find the detailed curriculum on
this landing page and so
i'll just show you this landing page and
i'll paste the link here as well
so you can find this information right
here
on this link
so if you scroll down
you will find here the full syllabus so
if you have any questions about the
syllabus and what it includes please
don't hesitate to reach out to us but
this is the full overview of the program
again it's fairly short but it's going
to be
good for those that are just getting
started with bioinformatics so this
program we ran it in the previous
semester as well we have quite a number
of people of students including graduate
and undergraduate students that have
completed this program and it really
can take a biologist somebody that knows
nothing about bioinformatics and help
them understand
why they should learn this or how to
apply it and at least will be useful to
read some papers that include
bioinformatics or if you're going to
submit a grant and you're going to
incorporate bioinformatics will provide
you with better terminology to interact
with your
bioinformatics core and kind of let them
understand what exactly you're trying to
do
so the other programs again these were
beginner programs the other programs
that we're going to talk about are
project oriented
so project oriented means that we're
expecting those that have completed the
other type of training not the
introduction to bioinformatics program
but genomics meta genomics and data
science to be able to submit to learn
skills that will allow them to produce a
project of their own
and that's really the best validation
that you're able to apply what you have
learned and we hope that you can do it
in a fairly short time
so to do that part of this omixlogic
portal
is an opportunity to
once you complete your profile to be
able to submit a project right on the
learn portal
and
apply what you have learned in this
training to a data set describing
everything that there was to
that you did and really focusing on
reproducible research so as you complete
your profile and you learn by acquiring
points by completing different course
work then you will be able to submit
this
project that we
that i will explain in a second but
that's the major differentiation between
what we call a basic program and an
advanced program so the fans programs
are really oriented for those that want
to use this for a particular project
and so i'll return to this towards the
end but let me briefly describe what
will be covered in the genomics program
and then i will go back to describing
what the project oriented component
really is
so for the genomics program which is an
intermediate program
we will cover uh the basics of genomics
the applications of
genomic sequencing data analysis to
study a variety of different examples
like germline mutations genetic diseases
cancer and similar things to that
so uh briefly to describe what i will do
today is i will cover some of those
basic things provide you with some
examples and then at the end i will go
back to this idea of project oriented
training that you can learn
in these programs that are going to be
coming up
so as you all know
dna especially the human dna is very
complex and it's organized in such a way
that we can
understand some of it but really we need
to have all the information about the
genome to be able to ask questions about
the dna not only that also the dna
itself is stored in a very compact way
and so to understand what information it
contains we need to understand the
organization of the dna which is
organized by chromosomes and so the
chromosomes are essentially these
strings of dna that are
attached to histones and
when we think of dna right the first
thing that we need to think about is
what are the actual elements that matter
right where should we look at and so
where we need to look at is typically
referred to as the whole exo right so
what are those specific regions of dna
that produce protein
genes so what we'll do in this program
is we will talk about coal exome
sequencing that helps us understand how
the genotype or what's written in the
dna defines the phenotype the phenotype
of an individual cell the phenotype of a
tissue of an organ or the whole organism
now it turns out that only one percent
of the human genome about one to two
percent of the human genome are protein
coding genes
and that number has significantly went
down from the original expectations that
researchers had when they were starting
to sequence the human genome
so today we have about 22 500 genes but
that number varies across different
research fields and so really we're
going to look specifically at that known
part of the genome which we call
the exome right the the part of the
genome that is being expressed
one of the basic applications of
genomics is to identify bugs in the code
how can we link specific variants or
differences from the reference that
allow us to
make assumptions that the
sequence change results in a particular
change in phenotype for example here you
can see how a mutation could change the
cell phenotype which in this case is the
red blood cell uh to be the sickle cell
right so that's sickle cell disease
is defined by one such change
what we will also look is how we can
start characterizing these mutations and
start understanding their functionality
how individual
nucleotides form tri nucleotide codons
and how changes in specific positions in
these tricodons result in the change at
the amino acid level we will talk about
different types of point mutations like
substitutions insertions and deletions
and we will discuss what are genetic
variants versus mutations versus
neutral mutations pathogenic mutations
and essentially mutations that don't
land
and the way that we will talk about this
is we will try to understand the changes
at the sequence level at the dna
nucleotide level
we will then try to understand what are
some of the thresholds that are used to
understand whether the mutations is the
mutation is a coding or a non-coding
mutation
where that mutation is found is it found
inside the gene at the promoter of the
gene at the splice junction of the gene
or whether it is silent and we will also
look at the impact of the non-coding
mutations and whether these non-encoding
mutations matter at all we will also
take a look at some examples of where
such germline mutations are known to
play a difference in phenotype and how
they affect the phenotype
so when we talk about these types of
mutations we will also apply those two
somatic mutations as well as germline
mutations and we'll talk about how to
find them and what type of sequencing is
required to be able to find them in a
with a level of confidence that you can
actually annotate them and interpret
them
so genomic variation that we will
discuss
will include
looking at individual single point
mutations
as well as structural rearrangements and
copy number variation as well and as i
already mentioned we will take a look at
how we can observe the impact of these
mutations
in in the sense of affecting a phenotype
and that could be either a disease or
that could be just a difference in
condition
we will also take a look at the
relationship between the specific known
genes that that typically
have these mutations at different levels
at the level of where they are found in
the chromosome what does the gene look
like in terms of what's being expressed
and what's the variation of expression
at the 3d structure of the protein that
that gene codes for and also at how
people validate that these mutations
actually cause the phenotype or a change
in function
now to understand all of this at the
practical bioinformatics level we will
also discuss how this data is generated
so we'll take a look at different types
of sequences as
uh and different methods of sequencing
including targeted sequencing amplicon
sequencing and whole dna sequencing that
is applied for genomics and to really
understand the process we'll take a look
at how the sequencing machine works and
what type of data does it produce
and when we come to that part of the
data we will actually look at what do
these files look like and so we'll try
to understand
what is the information that is encoded
in this dna sequencing data
and then how can we analyze this data
which we will start from by learning the
logic of analysis so really how can we
perform
alignment how can we find variance how
can we interpret the variance
structurally and how we can measure
relationships between sequences and
changes in the sequences
so here are some of the applications
that we will look at we will look at
the need to clean or pre-process our
data
we'll talk about the need for calling a
variant determining whether this is a
mutation and annotation how do we
actually know what this mutation could
be related to but we will also look at
additional applications of different
methods where we can either visualize
the data that we have or identify a
particular type of mutations like
germline or somatic mutations we'll
learn to work with genome-wide
dissociation studies where we need to
understand the relationship in a
population to a phenotype
and what is needed to make that kind of
an association
and we will also take a look at
downstream interpretation of the found
mutations so how can we actually know
what a particular individual mutation or
multiple mutations what do they mean and
how can we identify
other factors associated with that and
so here as an example we will use a
study that shows how we have individual
or monogenic
snips and how we can look at polygenic
snips where monogenic are strong
associations that are typically
rare but they are uh
commonly associated with the phenotype
or polygenic scores that are more
complex and how do we actually analyze
the data to try and determine what is
associated with what and this is
typically referred to germline mutation
so some of the things that you will
learn in this part of this course is you
will look at how to load the data how to
process the data how to find meaningful
associations and also how to provide a
report on what you have found using both
the tbi and for platform and coding in r
now beyond those we will also look at
some of the applications of genomic
sequencing for biomedical research and
there we will look at examples for drug
metabolism somatic mutations inherited
mutations rare genetic disease as well
as drug resistance in bacteria which is
going to be a little bit different but
with similar principles
as the part of that you will learn what
goes on behind those typical
reports that are provided to cancer
patients for example and how do these
studies that intend to understand the
mechanistic or statistically significant
mutations how do they use this research
to actually produce such results
also we will look at how cancer occurs
and we will use some examples the
commonly known and and something that
everybody has probably heard about like
p53 as well as less known as a and maybe
less understood
individual mutations or
multiple mutations that have high
association with a specific phenotype so
we'll talk about point mutations
insertions deletions and rearrangements
like copy number variations
so i also mentioned that other
applications of
sequencing might include finding
specific mutations responsible for
drug resistance like antibiotic
resistance and tuberculosis
or association between
variants identified in short sequences
for example we'll take some examples of
viral sequencing data to try and find
specific mutations that have been
associated with the phenotype
as a part of this training you will get
access to our online coding
which is like an element that you can
find inside the coursework where you can
practice how to
write code with a lot of guidance right
so one of the important parts of this
program is to provide you with the logic
of analysis and then introduce you to
practical skills that you can also take
with you and continue to learn on your
own
so when we will do that we will this is
just an example of an exercise where we
will take several uh dna sequences from
patients compare them to the wild type
and try to determine what should be the
specific
diagnosis based on this information that
we should give to a patient so again
some practical examples of how you can
use this type of
data and this type of analysis to
identify as some important information
for biomedical research
so in summary we will provide you in
this genomic program our mixologic
genomics program
a variety of examples and opportunities
to try to analyze whole exome sequencing
data
from humans and non-humans alike we will
introduce you to how this type of
analysis could be applied in basic and
translational research you will
understand the terminology and the
commonly used approaches for analysis
and will be able to perform those
independently as well
using the platform for logical and
user-friendly analysis
as well as learning how to take the
process data and extract from their
meaningful insights using some coding
skills not a lot but at least some in r
and we will also show you how to deal
with a variety of different
data types that you will be expected to
work with as you are introduced to
genomic data analysis
so to briefly summarize
the two programs that we discussed today
are introduction to bioinformatics
getting started with big data
bioinformatics
and genomics
now i think tomorrow we're planning to
do another orientation session that is
going to be dedicated to meta genomics
and data science which are more advanced
programs for those that already have
some uh basics in those fields like you
may might have some
background in microbiology or maybe you
are interested in data science which
will typically require you to have some
background with coding so you must have
at least a little bit of experience
coding in r or python because very
quickly programs will become
challenging for those that do not have
that background
so again how do you register for these
programs if you are interested
this is the page for introduction to
bioinformatics so again i put in the
link
in the chat for introduction to
bioinformatics and this is a page for
the genomics program
so the genomics program
sorry
the genomics
program
right here
these are the topics and the syllabus so
you will find here all of the specific
details
all of these programs are going to last
for three months so for the whole
semester
um the introduction to bioinformatics is
much
shorter in terms of what we typically
expect people to spend on that program
but you can take up to three months to
complete it
genomics and data metagenomics and data
science might require a little bit more
time
the process will be that you will have
all of the materials for example this is
a course on this portal that you
registered for already on the omix learn
portal
so here you will find some asynchronous
materials and every week you will have
an email with a video lecture that
connects these materials into a program
in addition to that you will have access
to our mentors so if you have any
questions along the way you're
struggling with some piece of code
you're trying to build a pipeline and
it's not working or you have a
conceptual question you would like to
understand some topic that you don't
think was explained well enough we will
have
two q a sessions per month that you can
join to ask all of those questions
now for hana is going to be the course
coordinator she's going to be available
for collecting those questions and
making sure that we have those questions
ready for whenever we have the q a
session and she will be able to point
you in the right direction for
registering for those q a sessions
what does a program actually look like
just uh
here
so a program
will have for example let's go to this
genomics
program
so this program as you can see will have
once you're registered
you will see here the full curriculum
and you will be able to see here the
video recordings that are sent to you as
well and complete those
and once you are signed up you will find
on your profile
that right here you will find whatever
program that you're a part of you will
find that mentioned right there for
example here this is a program that
already finished and once you have
finished you will find your certificate
of completion right here and also you
will be sent a pdf version of that
program at the end as well
so now for those of you that are from
lbrn
lsu or nepi uh maybe for hana you can
take a little bit more time to just go
over the process again how do you
actually
register yourself
if you're from lusu or ldrn
okay
let me share my
screen one more time
okay
so most of you already saw the flyer and
already filled out the forms to us
and we haven't of the names and
informations
um about uh you
and now like afterwards
you have to register for
to register for the courses and
it has to go through the louisiana state
university gene lab or the ilab
so this is um
this is the way that
so first thing is you have to have an
account
in the ilab
so most of the people like who are in
lsu or the lsu school of veterinary
science who have used the core facility
we you all have the account in the core
facility
however the people who are outside
louisiana state university
or maybe in the lbrn or somewhere else
you have to sign up for an account in
the ilab
so i will send you the link to sign up
after this orientation session i will
send out an email
with the link
and will help you out how to create an
account here first
so some of the
students undergrad or
graduate students already reached out to
me and saying that they don't see their
pi's name in the system so for those of
you if you don't see your pi's name in
the list just send me an email and with
the informations of your pi's name and
email address and also the phone number
we will add your pi's name in the system
then you will be able to register
so first after creating account you will
have to sign in
and then you will see a page like this
you will have your username and password
you will sign in and afterwards you will
see a page like this and you on the left
hand side
there will be
a tab called core facilities you have to
click on the core facilities
and then you have to select the serial
core facilities and services
then on the right hand corner on top
corner you will see the request services
so this is one of the
services that the core facility does so
you will select the training modules
under the request services up
tab
so once you get in there
you have to select the courses that you
want to take
so we already updated the name of the
courses for this semester so you will
see all these three names the
introduction to bioinformatics genomics
metagenomics and the big data analysis
uh on the left hand side and you will
select and if you have any specific
comments you can write in here
and then you can save this form and see
like submit it later or you can directly
send it
and submit it with the
after introducing the fund number so
those of you who are part of the lbrn
program or part of lsu or school of
veterinary science
uh you can just write
that here and we
this course is free for you so we are
gonna put some numbers here and it will
be free for you
however the people who are outside
losing a state university uh they have
to put their phone number where we
should charge for the courses
and then
you just submit the request to to us
so then we will go through the overall
information here and then we'll accept
it and that is how your registration
will be completed so i will send out
this information in an email afterwards
after this orientation session
and still if you have any questions just
send me an email i'll be i'm physically
like here in the school of veterinary
science on the third floor
whoever in english you are in the web
school if you guys want to see me or
like have any specific questions you can
see me or you can send me an email
i will try to help you in the
registration process or any other
questions if you have about the courses
so that's all india
okay thank you for anna again for those
of you that are at lsu
um you can find for hana or contact her
uh the same for lbrn and then if you're
a part of nepi
and you're from another institution
you can directly sign up
and you can just
mention in your profile which university
you're from and please use your
domain name from the university not
gmail or something like this so in
addition to this i wanted to mention
that this re this
orientation meeting has been recorded
you can find it right here
so you will be able to review any of the
program description that we kind of
shared with you today we already shared
with you the links to the individual
pages if you're interested in learning
more about the topics that are going to
be covered so i'm just going to put that
again in chat
this is the omex logic genomics
and this is the link to
introduction to bioinformatics
so if you have any additional questions
about the topics that we're going to be
covering
uh we'll stay here for another few
minutes to answer those questions
and for those of you that are interested
in metagenomics or data science
we
invite you to join us tomorrow at the
same time so we will review those as
well
um yeah if you do have any questions you
can put them in the chat
and if not again thank you for joining
today you will
maybe for hana you can add your email in
the chat so if anyone has any questions
they can reach out to you
so yes the courses are going to be a
synchronous because people have
different schedules for hana i think you
just sent that message just to me not
everybody
but if you do have questions there are
going to be twice a month an interactive
q a session that q a session will help
us
address any questions that you might
have
so
any technical questions or theoretical
questions we'll actually have
trained by information here that will be
able to answer your questions
okay do we have any programs on how to
handle isoform transcriptomic data yes
so we have again an asynchronous course
called
transcriptomics
in that course we discuss
all from the beginning to the end the
transcriptomic data analysis approaches
including single cell transform atomic
data how to work with iso form
transcriptomic data and others
and if you have any specific
questions that you want and you're
already familiar with the general terms
of transfer comics feel free to reach
out to me
my email is
pine.com
okay so charles is asking and working a
hospital lab facility and not yet taken
any post
grad program please what does the
program have for me since i'm on the
bench for now so i seem to be fascinated
with boundaries and data science so we
recommend starting with the introduction
to bioinformatics again introduction to
bioinformatics maybe i'll just share my
screen once again just briefly
i'll show you where you can get started
and kind of explore what direction is
most interesting to you
so if you go to the courses tab
you can click on
getting started right here
so if you click on getting started you
will see these are some of the basics
that you can begin with
and if you have any additional
interest you will see some examples in
the introduction to bioinformatics and
specifically here in the bytes and
molecules course so in the bytes and
molecules of course for example you will
find here applications of bioinformatics
to
um
to precision medicine to
space omnics to other things
and you have some introductory materials
on genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
protein structure and function etc so
this is a course that you can explore if
you're just getting started
all right well again thank you everyone
for joining today
we will be sharing this recording and if
you do have any additional questions
please feel free to email us
and tomorrow we'll cover the
metagenomics in the data science program
so if you're interested in those please
join us tomorrow at the same time
thank you and
and uh we hope to uh
yes it is the same zoom id and password
for the meeting tomorrow i believe
um
if you have been getting the emails
harris then please
check those emails from sonerica
excellent
okay thank you charles
okay excellent thank you for hana for
your help
and for everyone else that joined today
and we'll see you again tomorrow